JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture, you've been learning
about surface integrals, flux,
and the divergence theorem.
And I have a nice
problem here that'll
put your knowledge of
those things to the test.
So in this situation,
I have a hemisphere.
So this is a hemisphere.
It's the right half of
a sphere, so the part
where y is positive, or
non-negative, I guess.
So just the surface of that
hemisphere, and it has radius R
and it's centered at the origin.
So I have this hemisphere
and I have the field F, which
is given by y times j hat.
So it's just always
in the y-direction.
So I have this field and
I have this hemisphere,
and what I'd like
to do is I'd like
you to compute the flux of the
field through this hemisphere.
But as a hint,
rather than doing it
by computing the surface
integral by parameterizing,
what I'd like you to do is
to use the divergence theorem
to make your life a
little bit easier.
So why don't you pause
the video, take some time
to work that out, come back
and we can work on it together.
Hopefully, you had some luck
working on this problem.
Let's see how we
can go about it.
So the thing that we're
asked to compute--
let's give this a name,
just so we can refer to it.
So let's call this surface
of the sphere S. All right.
So we want the flux through
S. And so the flux through S
is the double integral
over S of our field F
dotted with the normal, with
respect to surface area,
so with respect to surface area.
So I guess this was a kind
of bad choice, this S. We've
got S that means-- this
S means the sphere,
this S just means surface area.
OK.
Hopefully, you can
keep those two sorted.
This is the thing that we want.
And we'd like to compute it--
rather than by parameterizing
this hemisphere, we'd like
to compute it by using
the divergence theorem.
So the divergence
theorem relates
the integral over a surface to
a triple integral over a region.
So what we'd like to find is
a solid region for which this
is all or part of the boundary.
Now this half
hemisphere-- rather,
half-sphere, this
hemisphere-- doesn't actually
enclose a region, but
there's an obvious region
that's closely
related to it, which
would be the solid sphere.
If you just filled in
that half-sphere there.
So then, for that solid
sphere-- so the right half
of the solid sphere, with radius
R, centered at the origin,
that hemisphere, that
solid hemisphere,
has a surface that
consists of S,
and it also consists of a
disc centered at the origin.
So it consists of--
I'm going to draw it in
right here-- it's this disc.
This one.
That disc right there,
together with our hemisphere
that interests us,
make up the boundary
of this solid hemisphere.
So I'm going to
call that disc-- I'm
going to give it a name--
I'm going to call it S_2.
So we want this
integral and we're going
to use the divergence theorem.
So the way we're going to
use the divergence theorem
is we're going to use the
divergence theorem to relate
this double integral
over a surface
to that triple integral.
But I'm going to have to get
S_2 involved because I need--
for the divergence
theorem to apply,
I need surfaces which
completely bound a solid region.
So what we know by
the divergence theorem
is that the double integral
over both S and S_2 of F
dot n hat with respect
to surface area
is equal to the
triple integral--
OK, so I guess I need
another letter here.
So I'm going to call this D
for that whole half-hemisphere,
the solid hemisphere.
So D, this is the
solid hemisphere.
So this D is the
solid hemisphere
that they bound--
of-- OK, so it's
the triple integral over
D of the divergence of F
with respect to volume.
So this is what the
divergence theorem tells us
and now we-- so OK.
So good.
So now what's going to be
nice is that in this case
this triple integral is going
to be very easy to compute.
And the surface
integral over S_2
is going to be easy to compute.
And so what we're going to be
left with-- after we compute
those two things, we'll be
able to subtract and get
just the surface
integral over S.
So lets think about
doing those things.
So first let's do the
surface integral over S_2.
The surface integral
over S_2 of F
dot n with respect
to surface area.
Well, what is F
on that disc S_2?
So let's go look at
our picture again.
So this disc is the disc
of radius R centered
at the origin in the xz-plane.
So it's in the xz-plane.
So that means it's in
the plane y equals 0.
So F on that disc is just 0.
It's the zero field.
It's 0 everywhere on that disc.
And if you take a surface
integral of a zero field
dot the normal vector, well,
0 dot the normal is just 0.
So if we come back over
here, this integrand
is 0 dot the normal.
So it's always 0.
So we're integrating 0.
So we just get 0.
Definite integral of 0 is 0.
Double integral of 0 is 0.
Great.
So this S_2, the
surface integral of F
is really easy to compute.
That's the first one we needed.
Now we need the triple integral.
So let's compute
the triple integral
over the solid
hemisphere of div F dV.
Well, what is div F?
Well, you know, so
div F is just the sum
of the partial derivatives
of the three components.
So in our case if
we go back and look,
well, F is 0 i hat plus
y j hat plus 0 k hat.
So when you take the
partial derivatives
you get 0 plus-- the
partial derivative of y
with respect to y is just 1,
plus-- from the third component
we also get 0.
So the divergence--
let's go back over here--
the divergence is just 1.
It's just a constant 1.
That's great.
So this triple integral
is equal to-- I'm
going to bring it
down here-- so it's
equal to the triple
integral over D of 1 dV.
But, of course,
when you integrate 1
over a solid region
what you get is just
the volume of that region.
So whatever this number is, it's
the volume of that hemisphere.
Well, OK, so what's
the volume of a sphere?
It's 4/3 pi R cubed.
So the volume of a
hemisphere is half of that.
So that's 2 pi R
cubed divided by 3.
So that's the triple
integral of the divergence
over the solid region.
So what does that mean?
So our integral, the integral
over S of F dot n with respect
to surface area is equal
to this triple integral
over D of div F dV minus
the double integral over S2
of F dot n d surface area.
And so we just saw that
this is equal to 2 pi
R cubed over 3 minus 0.
But 0 is 0.
So it's just 2 pi
R cubed over 3.
So let's quickly recap.
To start off with, we
just had this hemisphere.
And we're asked to
compute a surface integral
over this hemisphere of
a flux of this field F.
So rather than going ahead
and calculating it directly,
what we realized is that
by the divergence theorem,
we could consider this to be a
difference of a triple integral
minus another
surface integral such
that those two surfaces together
bounded the region that you
were triple integrating over.
So in principle, there
were many possible regions
that we could have chosen.
Many possible solid
regions that we could
have chosen to do that
triple integral over
and to use the other
half of its boundary.
But there's one
particularly nice one,
which is just the
solid hemisphere
of which this hemisphere
S was the boundary,
or part of the boundary.
And so then that gave us this
other part of its boundary
was this disc.
So we introduced this
new solid region, D,
and the rest of
its boundary, which
was this other
surface, this disc S_2.
And so then, by the
divergence theorem,
rather than computing
the integral
over our original
region S we could just
compute the triple integral
over the solid region
and the surface integral over
the other half of the boundary.
So sometimes that
won't be helpful.
Sometimes you'll
have an ugly field,
you'll have an ugly region,
things won't work out.
But in this case, it
worked out really nicely.
The triple integral
was easy to compute,
as we saw over here, because
the divergence was constant.
Because the divergence
was just equal to 1,
the triple integral
just gave the volume.
And the other surface
integral was also
easy to compute because F dot n
on that surface was equal to 0.
So integrating it was very easy.
We just were integrating
0 and we got 0.
So in this case, these choices
worked out very, very nicely.
They made our life
nice and simple.
And so in the end,
all we had to do
were these two almost
trivial integrals.
They didn't really require any
computation at all on our part.
And then a little
bit of subtraction,
except we were subtracting 0 so
even the subtraction was easy.
So that was what we did,
worked out very nicely,
2 pi R cubed over
3 was our answer.
And I'll end there.